the development deal Disney pulled the
plug on would have created 2,000 new
jobs with an average salary of 120 a
year Gian Carlos Soo from Vista media
tweeted this the truth is this project
died the day Chic was fired Iger hated
it it was a terrible idea and had
already been delayed until 2026 those
2,000 jobs were California transplants
mostly of whom did not want to move to
Florida because creatives like La this
article uh called it in November Alysa
Farah from The View saw that from Gian
Carlo and she wrote This I Believe Gian
Carlo is correct here but the political
problem is public perception the
governor picked a fight and the State
lost jobs and revenue she continued
having a major corporation come out and
say they left your state because of the
uncertain business environment is a huge
blow when one of the biggest selling
points on the right is about the free
state of Florida has been the business
environment she's doing exactly what
everyone in corporate media does she's
lying about what the real issue is